hey guys welcome back to your weekly
data stream recap and this week was kind
of slow because most of the crew like
Ramon and Damian were out at e3 but Eric
Pope was still there to give us some new
info so let's get started so the first
thing on the list is the quitter penalty
we talked about recently has been
released as of Monday which you guys
probably have noticed but if you have
not played for honor since then it has
been in effect the patch we talked about
last week with the shinobi nerf has been
released as well if you missed you can
click the annotation in the top right or
the description to see the patch notes
and there's also four new weekly content
there's going to be a new effect added
to the game called death mist which I'll
show to you right now
[Music]
so that looked all right that's going to
be costing you five but I noticed that
it kind of looks a lot like whirlwind
but more fog and less leaves so I don't
know if it's really worth it or not
there's also going to be a new call to
event which is called - I believe
elimination or Dominion they get the
elimination it's a new call to
elimination so probably try to play as
many elimination games as you can to get
your 2000 steal next up round 2 of
season 2 has just ended in the samurai
have won so congrats to the samurai
there's also three more rounds left so
there's plenty of time to beat the other
factions and take a win on the factory
more the live update 1.08 101 was
released yesterday which comes with
guard stance changes to all speeds or
the Garcias changing speed to all
characters is the same the one-shot
exploit was patched in multiplayer but
they made it so that it was patched in
campaign so revalue campaign
speedrunners can say is helm splitter
and swift strike are now interrupted or
not interrupted on block and the swift
strike reaction duration was shortened
by 800 milliseconds from 900
milliseconds the warden shoulder bash
can now be canceled into guard break but
only at the start of the animation and
not at the end and the shoulder bash
minimum stamina cost is increased from
10 to 20 and the maximum cost was
incurred was increased from 15 to 30
shinobi also got tons more nerfs his
doubled his double dodged can no longer
be connected into guard break his kick
area-of-effect is now smaller and
stamina was increased from 5 to 20 his
front kick has also had its range
reduced from 4.75 - for any
uninterruptible stance duration of that
attack is now changed from 200 to 600
milliseconds of the attack from 300 to
600 milliseconds so basically the very
front are the very half of the first
part of the animation is now
interruptible so if you were to hit
shinobi about half from the beginning to
halfway through of his anime animation
he will be canceled out of this kick
the only other character left was
warlord and whose throw back run
duration was reduced from 400
milliseconds and his throw left and
right run duration was reduced by 300
milliseconds meaning whenever you guard
break someone and then throw them he
likes to carry you a very long distance
with his shield the duration of how long
he can carry you was reduced by a bit
the revive has also been increased for
one extra second in skirmish in
elimination game modes and all
projectiles were reduced in damage I
didn't talk about this before I just
wanted to let everybody know what they
were and give a little quick refresher
there was also a few things that were
not noticed like Shinobi's front kick
range and the AOE and the wool the word
and shoulder bash as well so that that
was really just a quick refresher of
what it was also on top of the four
honor legends a very popular discord in
tournament hoster there hosting a new
tournament for all platforms I don't
know exactly what time zone it is I do
believe that in Europe though so
hopefully you can find that out the
dates are listed and the website is
listed as long as as with the discord so
you can sign up on their website to
participate if any of you do want to
participate there you go and that's
really all the dead stream was today it
was very slow week as I said because
Roman and Damion were out in III and
Eric Pope was ill in one of the studio
hopefully next week we'll get some more
questions on any more nerfs and boss of
characters or ranked mode or anything
else coming in the next couple of weeks
but anyway guys it's going to be really
the end of the video today I hope you
all did enjoy this very short video once
again I do apologize for the shortness
of this I couldn't really help it but if
you guys did like the video but give it
a like if you disliked it dislike if
you're new to this channel subscribe I
always put out some more four on our
content for all of you to enjoy like
patch notes and other discussion videos
and like I said if you missed the
yesterday's yesterday's video you can
click the annotation on the top right to
be taken to that or if you want to see
the patch notes I just discussed in full
bold point lists you can check the
description as well for that and I will
see you guys in the next video and peace
out